imagine um mundo onde as pessoas se
entendem
elas dialogam umas com as outras e elas
aprendem se compreender
nesse mundo as diferenças são vistas em
desconfiança
as referências são não precisam ser
atenuadas para que se atendam em
conflitos
ao contrário as diferenças o mam
elas são valorizadas quando eu olho com
uma pessoa que é diferente de mim olha
com muita atenção eu escuto essa pessoa
e de repente eu começo a perceber que
além da diferença
tem também a semelhança eu e ela também
somos iguais
eu sou você imagine esse mundo e eu digo
pra vocês que esse mundo existe esse
mundo existe mas nós precisamos aprender
a aprender a dialogar
se a gente quer mudar o mundo é fácil
acreditar que a gente vai ter uma grande
ação uma pessoa vai falar com uma coisa
muito diferente talvez você já não
pedissem mais nisso eu acho bom talvez é
muito melhor a gente acreditar que o
mundo vai mudar a partir de pequenas
ações que muita gente vai fazer
então vamos começar pequenininho vamos
começar pela nossa comunicação
comunicação uns com os outros
comunicação é uma coisa muito importante
através da comunicação por exemplo a
vida acontece se não tivesse uma boa
comunicação as células não se nutriam no
sangue
então na comunicação a gente diz que a
comunicação cria mundos sociais
nós podemos criar mundos sociais bons ou
muito ruim sabe aquelas situações onde
você entra numa comunicação com uma
pessoa toda travada toda ruim depois
demoram um século para poder fazer
aquele mal entendido ou a gente pode
criar uma outra coisa que tipo de
comunicação a gente precisa para criar
um mundo social que a gente quer
falando ainda de comunicação têm uma
outra coisa importante é a questão do
significado
eu acho que você já
há bem que as pessoas atribuem
significados diferentes aos mesmos dados
aos mesmos fatos a mesma coisa acontece
e eu vejo um jeito outra vez de outro
jeito
então como é que a gente vai conviver
se cada um vê as coisas de um jeito essa
questão da comunicação eu digo pra vocês
que existe uma conversa uma conversação
na comunicação que é capaz de resolver
essas situações de isolamento o problema
do significado essa conversa a gente
acha que a gente sabe fazer e que a
gente faz muito mas na verdade a gente
não sabe tão bem e faz muito menos do
que pensa é o diálogo
o diálogo é uma palavra usada de uma
maneira muito e precisa a gente chama
por exemplo de diálogo as conversas
entre os israelenses e os palestinos
as conversas entre os empregadores os
empresários e os sindicatos
as conversas por exemplo entre o pai o
filho filho que cair na balada ou pai e
devia ter um diálogo e não é
então vamos ver exatamente você sabe o
que significa a palavra diálogo diálogo
vem dia e logos dia não é 22 é de dia
significa através por exemplo o diâmetro
de um círculo a linha que passa através
do círculo ou uma cortina de afa na a
luz passa através dessa cortina e logos
logo significa muitas coisas
conhecimento palavra razão mas aqui nos
interessa que logo significa sentido
significado então diálogos um
significado que atravessam bom a maior
parte das nossas comunicações um
significado não atravessa ele não entra
completamente a gente fica num nível de
comunicação que é baseado nos
estereótipos ou nos preconceitos
então alguém fala alguma coisa eu já
estou julgando aqui
a priori o que essa pessoa falou antes e
sabia direito qual é a conexão que essa
pessoa
tem com isso vou dar um exemplo eu digo
pra vocês que eu sempre gosto de ser
pontual
nossa que cara chato e meu deus eu não
queria ser filho dele
ah eu também gosta de ser pontual esse
nível esse é o nível da personagem que
julga as coisas que a gente recebe na
comunicação de uma maneira muito
superficial
de acordo com a nossa experiência
passada mas não está claro não
atravessou ainda o significado da
pontualidade para mim então vocês podem
me perguntar bom mas porque você faz
tanta questão de ser pontual
vou responder para vocês que na
faculdade eu era o cara mais atrasado
que vocês podiam conhecer marcava às 9
horas chegava a 96 ou 10 porque porque
quando chegava na hora
é eu sempre tinha que esperar todo mundo
chegava atrasado então falei 'bom eu não
quero ficar esperando então me acostumei
mas aí fui morar num outro país e nesse
outro país as pessoas eram pontuais e
marcava às 9 horas
ninguém chegava nem 95 nem 5 das 9 horas
levei muita bronca porque chegava
atrasado mas aí depois eu comecei a
chegar na hora e percebi uma coisa muito
interessante é que era muito bom
as 15 para 9 estava falando com alguém
que eu queria estava cuidando de algum
outro assunto qualquer coisa que eu
quisesse sair a prolongar 15 minutos
naquela época dava pra chegar em
qualquer lugar onde esse trânsito maluco
mas eu tava no lugar às novas pessoas
estavam lá os 9 a vida rendia maravilha
pontualidade me faz bem
então deixa eu perguntar pra vocês
compreenderão o sentido da pontualidade
pra mim agora o sentido atravessou vocês
entendem de fato o que é que a
pontualidade é para mim muito bem isso
obriga vocês a serem pontuais também
imagino que não muitos de vocês devem
ter ideias diferentes a respeito da
pontualidade e o diálogo é isso é apenas
entendeu que o significado e alguma
coisa pra pessoa pode ser diferente do
meu mas eu compreendo essa pessoa
a página de compartilhar o significado
com ela
alguém poderia dizer olha pontualidade
comigo não só porque meu pai era muito
rígido a gente chegasse muito atrasado
era um caso
então eu não gosto de ser controlado
pelo relógio faz sentido não faz
igualmente então ambos têm razão quem é
que tem mais razão essa é a tentação é
saber que ele discutir para saber quem
tem mais razão o pontual não pontuou
os dois têm a mesma razão que o diálogo
é um tipo de conversa onde significados
diferentes podem ser compartilhados e
eles não precisam mudar um por causa do
euro podem mudar mas não precisam mudar
na verdade eu não estou querendo dizer
pra vocês que diálogo é a coisa mais
importante do mundo e é uma panacéia
para todos os males não é assim existem
outras conversas também são importantes
por exemplo uma discussão que é uma
discussão é quando entra no lugar
por exemplo eu sou de uma empresa que
está precisando fazer um planejamento
estratégico ou uma política pública no
governo mas a gente tem que ver várias
possibilidades analisar essas
possibilidades então escolher a melhor
delas
essa é uma conversa de discussão
perfeito maravilhoso precisamos a
discussão mas o que eu vejo acontecer é
que a gente tá tão formatado então
condicionado a discutir quando falou sou
pontual ou utilizar mas esse negócio
legal como se só houvesse uma verdade
então acho que a gente discute de mais
gente precisa aprender a usar a conversa
certa na hora certa
o debate por exemplo é outra conversa
importante debate aquilo que a gente vê
acontecendo na televisão quando existem
há os políticos que vão lá para ganhar o
seu voto
então como que se entra num debate a
gente entra para ganhar
eu não entro lá para dizer que o
programa político do meu concorrente é
melhor do que o meu
eu entro para ganhar mesmo isso tem um
lugar
então se eu tô armado e vem alguém bom
muito bem se essa pessoa me desarma
também então eu uso o debate que é uma
conversa de destruição para desarmar
por exemplo tudo tem o seu lugar então
eu não quero dizer pra vocês que o
diálogo é tudo mas o que eu quero dizer
é isso aqui existe em três pilares de
conversação na nossa civilização
o debate onde eu entro para vencer a
discussão onde eu entro para analisar e
o diálogo onde eu entro para estabelecer
a conexão para as pessoas o que acontece
na nossa sociedade é que essas três pés
fossem os pés de uma mesa essa mesa
estaria completamente torta
nós fazemos muito mais debate muito mais
discussão do que o diálogo que é a
conversa que nos conecta uns com os
outros
estamos muito desconectados a gente acha
que a gente está conectado mas a gente
nunca teve tão desconectada basta você
que tenta frequenta através do facebook
você vê o que acontece quando as pessoas
possam alguma coisa a respeito de
política hoje alguma coisa a respeito da
religião seja qual for esses assuntos
polêmicos
então essa desconexa são a conversa que
resolve essa desconexa é o diálogo e pra
mim as pernas dessa mesa tão
completamente tortas assim
desequilibradas
então você quer fazer um bom diálogo o
que você precisa para recompor a conexão
com as pessoas
três condições a primeira condição é
igualdade bom pais e filhos professores
e alunos chefes e funcionários
se a gente parte para o diálogo já
desigual achando que não sabe mais o que
o outro pode falar mais do que o outro
não vai ter diálogo né agora igualdade
que estou falando é essa aqui ó tem duas
concepções uma é aqui do lado esquerdo
de um jogo de futebol e tal tinga
jogando está todo mundo querendo olhar
mas tem um grandão um médio e um
pequenininho três caixotes o grandão não
precisa do caixote
o médio mais ou menos e o pequenininho
não adianta um caixote para ele mas a
gente vai serviço de voz da igualdade
para todos aqui um caixote para cada um
não resolve mas olha que outra que
distribuição criativa que existe aqui a
gente tem o grandão que não precisa
short um médio que precisa de um e um
pequenininho que precisa de dois então
na hora de fazer o diálogo a gente
precisa colocar as pessoas em posição de
igualdade dessa igualdade que estou
falando é a terceira com a segunda
condição pra falar do diálogo é ouvir
ouvir com empatia ouvir é muito
interessante todo mundo diz que falar e
ativo e ouvir é passivo
eu pergunto pra vocês já tentaram falar
alguma coisa para alguém que não está a
fim de escutar
então é esse que é a força do ouvir
ouvir da força para falar aquilo que eu
tô falando tá sendo alimentado por vocês
estarem ouvindo a gente diz no diálogo
que a pessoa que ouve muito mais
importante que a pessoa que fala porque
a energia está lá e empatia empate assim
eu vou me colocar no lugar do outro
puxa parece fácil pra fazer isso eu
preciso me esvaziada as coisas que eu
tenho no meu mundo
os meus julgamentos as minhas
experiências podem entrar no mundo do
outro para entender ele do jeito dele
não do jeito que eu sou cada um é um
cada mundo é um mundo diferente então se
eu entendo outros termos dele eu vou
compreendo vejo um monte de coisas nem
com sim preciso falar pra ele certas
coisas ou ela as coisas que eu vejo que
talvez sejam ameaçadoras
mas eu volto para o meu mundo bom se eu
vou pra lá tão inseguro no meu mundo não
consigo ver a verdade dele porque ameaça
minha não tem empatia pessoas inseguras
não conseguem ter empatia
elas não conseguem ver a verdade do
outro então em vez de empate que elas se
tornam fanáticas elas se tornam
fundamentalistas
quanto mais diferença você vê no outro
mas você precisa terminar afirma que a
única verdade a sua então percebem como
é importante saber a empatia praticar a
empatia ea terceira coisa é falar dos
pressupostos pressupostos é assim quando
falei da da pontualidade
eu falei dos meus pressupostos são as
minhas crenças as minhas experiências
que fazem com que acredite naquilo que
eu acredito
então tem situações em que não dá pra
falar dos pressupostos por exemplo o
chefe quer que o empregado faça coisa do
jeito que ele quer
sem dizer por que então se não tem
possibilidade de falar dos pressupostos
não tem diálogo detalhe bobo coisa muito
importante antes de ficar criticando os
pressupostos do outro
deixa eu olhar primeiro para os meus
isso é uma lição de humildade
então o diálogo essa conversa que
consegue recompor a conexão social
compartilhar o significado não o fato
não informação é aquilo que faz a gente
ser uma sociedade unida um grupo unido
uma escola unida é o significado não são
os fatos a gente compartilhar seus
significados
vocês jovens têm a oportunidade de
estarem com uma conexão como nunca
existiu na história então é a grande
oportunidade que vocês fazem uma
conversação que una as pessoas e que
revele a conexão que acontece entre
vocês
o diálogo não cria conexão o diálogo
revela
nós já estamos conectados o que a gente
não sabe a gente fica pensando em coisas
exteriores
então poder estátua seja lá o que for e
não olha para a conexão que acontece
espontaneamente dentro de nós
essa conversa que libera a conexão
espontânea é o diálogo então prática o
diálogo até nas redes sociais em todo
lugar procure compreender o outro entrar
no mundo do outro não tem certo e errado
no diálogo no diálogo tem eu
compreendo-o eu não compreendo e eu vou
me despedir de vocês com essa fala de um
poeta persa do século 13 e rume para
além das idéias do certo e errado tem um
território
eu me encontro com você lá brigado